different burlingame thank you she lost
her brother on 9/11 2001
you know Deborah we've become friends
over the years and you have been such a
strong powerful voice against radicalism
you know we're seeing the impact of
believing something is naive as North
Korea if we bribed them they're going to
stop the nuclear program they don't
didn't President Obama makes this
idiotic deal with Iran and I think back
and I think that you lost your brother
that day house are we really that stupid
that we don't understand the mentality
of evil in our time we're not that
stupid but we have a leadership and I
don't I'm not confining that to
politicians but also the cultural
leaders the thought leaders in our
country the the heads of Middle East
Studies departments in colleges and
universities who are obsessed with you
know something called hate speech and
worrying about the other and you know if
we had those people running the show in
World War two we might have had a quite
a different income outcome there the the
the way President Trump talked today
about the enemy was very important to me
so important to me and so refreshing to
me that I sort of knuckled my into the
Rope line so I could thank him for
simply saying that our loved ones were
murdered that day that is the first time
I heard a president since 9/11 used the
term murder and I felt it was really
important to say to thank him for that
and he actually said something
interesting to me he said my people
didn't want me to use that word and I
decided to say it anyway and I said well
I'm glad you did
and I got to tell you Shawn
I heard from 9/11 family members today I
hadn't spoken to them and they said did
you hear use the word murdered because
it bothers us when we hear euphemisms
like they were lost or they were taken
from us and when we see these mass
casualty attacks outrageous attacks in
least in in Orlando in in London in
Brussels
San Bernardino where they are targeting
or good civilians children and there's
all this worry about using the wrong
words to describe the the killers who
did it it was refreshing to hear this
today and one of the things that if I
may say III I learned was reading one of
the affidavits from Khalid Sheikh
Mohammed that was taken from him and
entered into evidence in the Masami
trial he said that they absolutely
planned a second wave of attacks but
were basically knocked on their heels
what they didn't imagine was the
aggressive response by the American
people by the Americans and that's what
gets it done the right thing yes I Debra
I gotten to know you over these years
and your voice with all you've been
through has been extremely powerful over
the years my thoughts and prayers with
you this day to thank you for being with
Sean tonight I appreciate it so much you
have been a very good friend and a good
friend the American people same with you
Thank You Debra Burlingame